我們先去偷看他意思怎麼準備好了
惡魔的手衝手法
幹兩板
很厲害
非常厲害
Let's be it
Just a let's be
It's not a rule
哈囉 大家好
我們今天要來帶大家揭秘
日本咖啡師
他的手沖秘訣
我們最近特別邀請了
Philocopia破骨折
他們店裡面的首席咖啡師
來到台灣
而且他這次客座就帶來一個
現在在他們店裡
最新的手沖手法
惡魔的手衝手法
但是
幹兩板
等一下就來請他來跟大家分享
哎呀 哈囉
哦
就這樣開始了
這場活動除了手鬆以外
也會出意識嘛
所以目前Rikto正在測試意識
哦 so nice
它香氣好讚哦
台灣的品牌
哦
已經沒了 喝不到了
我們先去偷看它意識怎麼組備好了
我覺得這滿有趣的
你如何調整
的標準
第一次我做了一個正式的
1 2 個
我用19g 和38g
我開始從這裡
我會做更強的 更強的
可能是同樣的 長時間和短時間
調整蒸籤
然後調整這個地方的氣氛
我覺得這個地方
我們可以做更強的 更強的
這三杯分別是他剛才萃取出來
要來做測試的
中間這杯是刻度6 這杯是5.5 這杯是6.5
濃度就會這邊比較濃 然後這邊中間
然後這邊是最輕鬆的 試試看
這兩個頭長的杯
就是想說你臉的比較好
第二杯做的是這個
它是在細的
這個前面是飛的
然後所有都沒有進來一起
有點跟他們暗沉
很好笑
我覺得這個就完全不同的方向
然後拉比較開來的
這個 它更容易被我感激到
我個人喜歡最最最最最最最初的那個
我比較喜歡中間這杯
平衡度最好
好
我們吃的最多的食物
30分鐘
非常強的水果凋性
比較強的水果凋性
可能水果凋性是70-80g
乾杯
非常好
非常甜
哇好甜喔
喝起來就是很香的水果凋性
有一點香料感
非常非常好
水質非常重要
I'm using Best Milk
對
lucky boys
鮮奶真的很重要
因為我們這次特別為了台灣blend
然後挑了五支不同的鮮奶
最後選出這個鮮乳房幸運兒
我們現在要設定手沖的產術
每間店的磨豆機啊水質啊
然後還有整個吧檯狀況都不一樣
所以進到一個新的店裡面都需要全部重調這邊它的水很好所以它的風味都出來了那昨天台北場是風味都出來了所以我們調的方向不太一樣現在在調的是那個後韻嘛
Aftertakes
就是它長不長
還有它的口感是乾的
還是剛剛好很圓潤
還有就是我很在意它第一口進去
它是會開花嗎
還是它是在你的時候上很尖銳
你說Aftertakes怎麼調
比如說濃度的話
我們就是調的研磨度
那個剛剛的研磨度第一把
我就準備有點濃到就是我覺得會有點暗
太細
有點細整體沒有開花
那我現在其實我覺得濃度有比較好
我們調出一點濃度比較好了
但是我們想要讓它更加的飽滿一點
所以這是我們接下來想要去調的
你會怎麼調的
其實剛剛我第一把的話是暗
暗的話我覺得是整體粉太幼了
所以我會往處裡面調
調的話它的整個會比較明亮一點
第二段的話我覺得有明亮的
但是它有點薄
所以我剛剛第二把就拉長的那個時間
拉長的時間
本來是40-30-30
我一般是40-40-40
現在我們覺得
Aptake好像又有點口感比較乾一點
所以我們要讓它再倒
有時我們要做招勻
檢查所有的咖啡
這次我用了冰糖
冰糖有很多類型的
混合
現在要檢查一下
有些色、尺寸、或是有些失敗
這是太暗了
這是太明顯
有些失敗
像是蚊子或是失敗的
或是破壞的
像這樣
破壞的芋子
有時會有些太過分
再撐一次看挑了多少豆子
然後再撲進去
好
其實我想要更加酸的
更加酸的大小
但是我沒有更加酸的
今天我用了4次
這個大小的大小的 recipe
我總是調整的
味道
大小的大小
咖啡的大小
温度是40-50度的
我已经改了这个设计
这个设计是比较稳定的
我用了短短的时间
你可以用确的冰箱
你可以用短短的时间
如果你不能用确的
你的冰箱更加稳定
你可以用短的时间
如何是温度?
温度是用高度的
這個水流是亮度的,對嗎?
亮度的,對嗎?
我用的設計是90度
我用的亮度更亮度,
我用的高度,
更暗度更暗度更暗度
這個就是只用一個水流
它不是一個水流
我們可以調整整整個數字
我會用水流的水流
因為如果我沒有水流因為糖水平均衡不一樣然後再加上水平均衡我做的水平均衡
然後再加上水平均衡
我先加上水平均衡
因為我們要加上水平均衡
這就是由 Captain Georgi的
對,他在年代的一年代
對,對
首先是中間的
然後一點點圓
中間一點點圓
好,OK
這個咖啡很軟,但很明顯
我用50克的第一次給我
比較普通的一種,我用40克
多少次?
30-40克
這次是40克的,或者是一種圓
第二次給我
中間,一圓
好
混合好
但是我主要是中心
中心的
因為這個酵的泡沫是很深的
中心的泡沫
我需要泡沫的泡沫
多少克?
120克
1分鐘10秒
我用了閉嘴的
然後300克
是有不同的地方是中的方法
每次用中的方法,中的方法
1分40秒,我開啟,轉動,等它煮的
OK
不錯
這是這個大小的餐廳
嗯哼
它是40%的
30%的
嗯哼
但是如果你可以用
Course grind
你可以用40%
40%
完成2分鐘20
然後這個比較均勻
嗯 好香
好香
嗯
Nice
我們來試試
請
就 いただきます
いただきます
哇 滋滋
非常棒
活動開始前半個小時
可能快20個人
這次邀請日本人的咖啡室在台灣客座
其實我們辦了三場
台南 台北 台中各有場
但是一個客座的巡迴
那前兩場我們也有一起準備
所以根本忙不到完全沒有時間進
可以囉 那我們就 Let's go
哎呀 準備啦
我跟你說
這是台中場
這邊的 Espresso 萃出來真是
爆炸好喝
這三場下來
我們每一場都覺得有一些獨特的地方
但是以我個人喜好來說
在台中喝到
我覺得近期最驚人的Espresso
然後這是他做出來的愛爾蘭
小姐姐咖啡好喝嗎?
啊~~~~~
日本人叫我小姐姐這樣可以嗎?
這樣嗎?
It's all ok
超級爆炸的果香
溫潤的甜
就是他不是那種
蔗糖或是果糖那種
很直接的甜感
他是被包在整個酒體
然後還有鮮奶油裡面這次的鮮奶油我們也是選了一個比較清爽的奶霜它就是這個那你是這個奶油是誰選的啊?真的!懂選謝謝妙麗好這次就會特別選這種融合性比較高
它有一點點是植物性的奶油
一點點是動物性的奶油
那這樣子的話它會更清爽
那配在這樣的飲品裡面它會更適合
然後它也是日本人熟悉的品牌
它是來自日本的中澤
他們特地為台灣氣候製作乳霜
來咖啡展咖啡展
他怎麼覺得我配手我要拿這個
好像在合起來一樣
我們這趟呢跟Filo Cofia的咖啡師
總共跑了三個客座
台北台中台南各一場
而且是非常精實從下午一路到晚上
每一天都是從下午一路到晚上
然後為了備料我們也是要早上進去
然後我覺得有發現日本的咖啡師
在整個手沖的流程的細節上面非常的講究
他們一定會挑豆
因為他說那個沒有調豆真的會差很多
調整到最喜歡的研磨度
再來是在注水前都會習慣先讓湖管去熱水
的同樣剛才也有講
他都會先讓水出來一點點
然後讓整個管子先變熱
因為他說當然會移成到味道
因為悶蒸的時候水量其實本來就少
那一段確實可能會降溶
對對對
在很多細節上你就可以感覺到
他們其實對咖啡的沖煮上面非常的用心
其實我覺得真的是文化上差很多耶
因為上次在台灣
我們可能比較習慣或者是大家就是真的比較害羞
所以我們就是習慣是拿到咖啡
然後以這杯咖啡為主
然後拿到咖啡就完成了這次的體驗
可是我覺得在日本咖啡市的眼中的咖啡體驗
它包含了更多的環節
那我覺得這也是他們這次來他們最想要帶給大家的
也有發現台灣和日本的咖啡文化真的差異很大
像這次呢Chuck and Rifto 他們就是帶手沖和拿鐵
台灣這邊我們就準備了一杯特長
他們就覺得有發現台灣的這個電子啊
有很多各種特調
Mixle喝得很開心
因為他說在日本是完全無法想像
有咖啡廳會出這種特調
回過頭來到茶的文化也是
就是台灣茶它就自然而然的
也變成手搖引系列
可是日本的茶道
它就是一樣很專精在沖茶的本身
對對對
然後用不同的方式沖茶
所以就也很有趣
整個民族性
然後大家在意的事情
其實真的都不一樣
那以上就是我們這次
跟日本咖啡是合作的新的
這次Liftour分享的手風手法呢
也可以在我們的IG上面看到完整的介紹
從頭到尾每一個段落的注水以及時間
其實經過這次最想要跟大家說的
還是如果有機會真的非常非常值得
直接去店裡體驗他們這樣面對面的窗酒服務
因為他的感覺真的是跟只喝一杯咖啡很不一樣
然後呢我們最近在LINE上面有我們的社群
如果大家喜歡分享咖啡
然後也喜歡討論咖啡的話
都歡迎加入
因為在裡面呢目前已經有快1000人了
我們在群組裡面會跟大家分享各種咖啡的資訊
也有專門針對手衝或器材的小群
以及專門針對跑店的群組
所以如果大家有興趣的話都可以加入
其實資訊真的很重要
很長東西一出來
然後兩分鐘賣完
就沒了
所以如果想要知道最新消息的話
記得加入我們的LINE
那我們今天影片就到這邊結束了
如果喜歡影片的話也點個喜歡
然後也分享給你有在喝咖啡的朋友們
好 那就下次見囉
掰掰
优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive